one of them suddenly aimed their gun
towards me because I was standing right
in front from a distance and
shot me on the face the first bullet I
received on the face
um I still remember that I screamed I
screamed really loudly because
that was probably one of the first
bullet that broke my teeth and my
maxilla and that pierced through my face
[Music]
so I was born in the Northwestern sides
of Pakistan and in a city called
beshawar I think since my childhood my
parents wanted me and my
siblings to get quality education so my
school life was
my my whole life probably like
um it was it was the only place where I
would go it's probably one of the best
schools in the city and I had friends
there my best friends which were kind of
like my second family because you know
you have breakfast with them in the
morning because it would go so early it
was a military school so it would start
really early and we had to like wake up
at five in the morning and then go there
and you have lunch with them so it was
kind of like a second family to me
are you able to just kind of touch on
the political situation in Pakistan at
this time so I think um around 2007 I
would say things started going wrong in
the especially in Peshawar that was the
city most affected by terrorism and uh
before that the Taliban or the terrorist
group when they came to the cities like
bishar and and there was like there was
um probably Bomb Blast and suicide bomb
attacks on a daily basis and
um my family my parents my mom and my
dad there would be worried all the time
they would be watching news all the time
and the day I realized that something
was going wrong in in our city was when
um I think there was a few people in our
neighborhood and that died in a Bomb
Blast in the suicide bomb attack and
when I saw their family and their family
members and Friends crying and shouting
and that's when I realized that things
are not going really well as I thought
around me and how old were you at that
point I was around like probably around
10 8 10 9 something like that
it was the day of 16 December where it
started as a normal day and I went to
school as per routine sat with my
friends we had a breakfast we were
chatting about a normal stuff Cricket
politics uh WWE everything so we were
discussing these things and then I was I
was the head boy at school at that time
so
one of my teachers came up and they told
me that we are having a first aid
lecture in the auditorium so I should
tell all the students in year rates and
year 9 that they should be heading to
towards Auditorium and I think most of
the students I saw they always
celebrating and were kind of happy that
they're going to miss lessons today due
to the first eight lectures so
um we we went to the auditorium and
everyone sat down and the first aid
lectures started and
things things were going normal at that
time in I still remember my friends
because I was the head boy so I was kind
of like on the stage and my friends from
the audience would make like these funny
faces to make me laugh and
um
then all of a sudden we heard a noise
there was a there was a noise uh it was
a loud noise and
um I think some of the some of the
students
um just jumped like they were they
weren't expecting it and the others
started laughing at them that they got
scared and uh then we again continued
like no one really paid attention to
that and then uh we heard those noises
again and this time it was consistent
like those started getting louder and
louder and getting more consistent
that's when everyone in the auditorium
like was silenced and everyone was
looking up to the teachers that what is
happening and
um I think at that time I was assuming
that it was a military drill and most of
us too so were most of the students and
but when those sounds started getting
even more louder that's when
um I had a bit of a doubt and everyone
was like a legend like scared well like
what is happening and I looked at one of
my teachers there in the auditorium I
was like what's what's happening and uh
they told me that oh don't worry it's
nothing it's it's just gonna be okay and
I was like okay but what is this like we
don't know and then our teachers started
locking all the doors in the auditorium
uh
and um that's when like most of the
students in there started getting more
scared now and they started getting more
anxious like why are the teachers
locking the doors and I saw a few people
like with shadows standing outside and
when they realized that the door was
locked they started kicking it they
kicked it once and when they kicked it
the second time the door broke and they
came in everyone started going under
their chairs I still remember I could
see everyone because I was still on the
stage and I I looked at my teacher and I
was a bit like scared and I was like
what what is happening like just tell me
like what's happening like and then they
started shooting they started shooting
all of a sudden they started shooting
people at the back and and I was in a
shock I I couldn't believe my eyes I was
I was just standing still I couldn't
move I didn't know what to do my I just
went blank one of them suddenly aimed
their gun towards me because I was
standing right in front from a distance
and
shot me on the face the first bullet I
received on the face
I still remember that I screamed I
screamed really loudly because
that was probably one of the first
bullets that broke my teeth and my
maxilla and that pierced through my face
and I I fell down on the floor and I
still couldn't believe it like what was
happening I was I was still in a shock
and I was I was in pain I was in shock
and I I didn't know what was happening
around me and then I saw a few of my
friends getting shot in their heads
because I was as I was lying down and
and my brain was just wasn't accepting
this situation
I was like this is this is not true this
is a dream like this can't be true like
my my friends just died in front of my
eyes like they they were just talking to
me like a minute ago and they are no
more with me and here I am dying like
about to die as I was lying down there I
was I was I don't know what what
happened but I just said to myself that
no I'm I'm just gonna try to survive I'm
uh I'm gonna give it my best like I'm
still breathing I was I was telling
myself that this was I I was just
putting my hand on my mouth and uh the
first time I tried to put my hand on my
face my hand went in because it was open
it had to open up so when
um I just kept telling myself because I
had no one to console me so I was I just
kept consoling myself that I'm still
breathing I'm still breathing and I was
I was just breathing and I was like I
just putting my hand on my mouth and and
then again I'm like I'm still breathing
I'm still breathing it's I'm still alive
one of them
um saw me like that I was I was still
moving and I was still doing moments and
and they shot me again
um they shot me again they kicked me to
see whether I was still alive
um and they were they were checking
every student in the auditorium they
were they were they were going around
and they were checking everyone whether
if if anyone would move they would start
shooting at them again my friend lying
down there in front of me like me lying
down on the floor looking at them and
they they were dead they were no more
and I was I was just about to to die
um
I I still remember that
after like uh
a few minutes like five ten minutes
um
they left the auditorium and at that
time I was lucky that my senses were
still working I could still see things a
bit blurry I could still hear things I
could still think
and
um I was I heard some people saying that
they have left some students saying in
Auditorium they were mumbling to each
other like they had left so I was trying
to wave my hand I was trying to like
call like someone so that they can help
me get up and move uh uh but I think it
was it was a chaotic situation and it
was it was a shock for everyone as well
they were kids themselves so there was
there was no one to help uh they they
just started running outside and
um at that time I I didn't realize that
I was shot on my leg and my arm as well
because the pain in my face was so much
that I didn't pay any attention to my
leg or my hand like and my wrist as well
because they kicked me when the
terrorist kicked me my wrist tracked
kind my right wrist cracked so I didn't
pay attention to any of those injuries
because I had no idea I had them my
whole Focus was on my face that uh my
because it was it was so painful when
there was no one to help me I I tried to
drag myself I tried to crawl I tried to
drag myself I couldn't get up I couldn't
stand up I tried to but I couldn't so I
tried to drag myself and I tried to
crawl and somehow I managed to get out
of the auditorium there was no one to
help me there was there was a class
about six to eight meters away from me
and
I was trying to get there because uh it
was an es7 class and I was trying to get
get there but I had lots I had lost so
much blood and I had so so many injuries
that it was it was really really hard
for me to even like move one meter and
when I tried to do that it took
everything out of me those six to eight
meters took everything out of me and I
managed to reach that place I managed to
reach the door and then my body had lost
all its strength I was just telling
myself that I shouldn't just close my
eyes shouldn't let myself go to sleep if
if someone is coming here to rescue me
or these people they would think that I
have died so I have to stay awake to let
them know that I'm still alive and there
was there was a tree a big tree outside
of school and I was looking at that tree
and
um when the fires when the shooting was
still going on you can still hear the
shooting you could still hear the Bomb
Blast and
the birds were flying from that tree
there was capturing so
um I still remember I was I was I just
said to myself that I wish I was one of
these and I could fly away from here
like them easily after 10 minutes there
was a military person that came and they
picked me up from the door and they they
saw me lying down in front of the door
and they picked me up and they put me in
an ambulance
I had
um been shot with bullets on my face it
was multiple bullets on my face and
um my hand my arm and my my right knee
was shot with bullet as well and I had
got like some splinters at the back of
my neck it was from the blast and stuff
um
and I had with with my face injuries
were the most severe injuries that I
sustained I lost all my appetites my
maxilla my jaws and the base of my nose
was completely broken and it still is
and the right side of my face was
completely blown away so at first my
family didn't know that it was me
because they still had doubts because I
had sustained injuries on my face and my
face was completely covered with
bandages so in the initial days my
family was was was really really
confused my dad had recognized me from a
t-shirt that he gave me a few days
before the attack so that's how he
recognized me during that whole time had
you realized like what was actually like
going on at that time to be honest I
still had no idea when I got short when
I went to the hospital I had no idea why
these people shot me of my friends
I have had nightmares even when I after
a few months when I was in in my room in
the hospital I would have nightmares I
would have dreams and I kept on looking
at the door when I was in ICU because
that shock when I saw them breaking in
the auditorium I kept on looking at the
door in hospital as well that someone
might break through that and just come
in again and I only knew about a few of
my friends that I saw at that time that
died but I didn't know about most of
them and I didn't know what had happened
to them
that time I was about like 12 10 years
old and
those friends had spent like about eight
years of their life with me so that was
that was my whole life for me it was a
short life so it was it was my whole
life for me and I had known them for my
whole life today so
when I when I saw them that their names
were on the list that people had died
the first thing that was shocking for me
was oh when I saw that 132 kids in our
school were killed and uh my heart just
sank like I was like I was just praying
that please none of my best friends be
on it like I was I was just praying and
um when I when I saw their names and all
of their names were on the list
uh
that's that's when I
I just went in a shock I I couldn't
believe it at that time I was
as like this is not true I
I haven't seen them I haven't even seen
their bodies yet like they they can't
like when
when sometimes when you just don't see
your loved ones like
like that you you don't really accept it
you your brain your heart doesn't accept
that they know more with you I would I
would be crying I'd be telling myself
that you know what if I would have done
this whatever I would have laid down and
I could have survived I wouldn't have
got shot and then I could have saved my
friends
and and the fact that you know I was I
was the one that uh called most of them
to the auditorium uh because I was the
head boys told by the teacher so that
guilt was kind of like really really
like
um
making it difficult for me uh and I was
I was It was kind of killing me from
inside my mom goes to me and she's like
uh what what will happen if you cry now
or if you uh just you know go in that
darkness that you know you just
has nothing to do with life now what
will happen will your friends come back
with that
uh will it change anything and
I had no answer to that and then she
tells me that
instead of crying and sitting here what
you should be doing you should recover
you should try to recover work on your
recovery and do something for them do
something that you know know other
people or none no other religious
friends should be
martyred or like kids like that you
should be getting up and doing something
for them
going through like a near-death
experience especially so young how do
you think that's changed your
perspective on on life I think
uh before this incident I had no purpose
and I mean I was young as well but you
know I didn't realize the value of life
I didn't realize the value of Education
uh that that's what it gave me like a
sense of realization how important this
thing that I'm doing and I'm taking for
granted is I was I I'll just say simply
that you know before this incident like
I just wanted to live for myself and now
I want to live for others
what would you I suppose want people to
know about your classmates that lost
their lives
I think I just want them to know that
you know they were they were there to
get education they they want there to
fight anyone and they were they were
innocent they were all innocent and uh
they were killed brutally for just
getting education they were killed
brutally for just uh wanting a future a
bright future for themselves they were
Brave they were they had they all had
Bright Futures
they were all someone was future army
officers some of them were future
politicians businessmen if they all had
aspirations they all had dreams that
were just shattered in in a few minutes
that were just taken away by a few
gunshots in life you know you life is
not what you think will happen life is
what happens to you so it's a hard hard
pill to swallow but sometimes you just
have to accept and live with that
reality
don't ever take the opportunities or the
education or you know whatever life
opportunities you have for granted
[Music]
I bought this
of people
um
being fed to these dogs I was so
terrified